so after months of indecision MPs have
finally voted for a general election
labour backs a general election
which means an end to the political
stalemate here in Westminster we will
not allow this paralysis to continue but
well they Anna's political journalist
prepares to head out on the campaign
trail what does that mean for brexit MPs
had noted worst Johnson when he tried to
get his brexit bill through the Commons
in just a couple of days so the nose
knows which means he paused the whole
process in its entirety mr. speaker I
must express my disappointment of the
house has again voted for delay so now
it's an election that means no
Parliament no MP is no debates no votes
and no brexit bill but all those
tortured hours of debate about brexit in
the Commons chamber might not be wasted
if Boris Johnson wins the election if
he's back in number 10 and the
Conservatives have a big majority he'll
bring his brexit bill back to the
Commons just over my shoulder and he'll
have enough MPs to get it through a vote
which means it will finally become law
and the UK will leave the European Union
but just when you thought brexit was
over it isn't if Boris Johnson gets that
brexit bill through then he has to still
come back to the comments to talk about
the future trading relationship and that
means more debates and more votes in
Parliament until he can get an agreement
with the EU but on the future
relationship we drink more Italian wine
than any other country in Europe 300
million litres of Prosecco and a forest
Johnson doesn't win well it could be a
Labour government led by Jeremy Corbyn
today we launch the most ambitious and
radical campaign country's ever seen and
his first plan is to tear up the
agreement that Boris Johnson reached
with the European Union and try and get
his own he'll be hopping on a Eurostar
off to Brussels to try and start those
talks all over again if the European
Union allow him to and once he's got a
new deal if he gets one then he'll bring
it back to Parliament and finally take
it out to the country in a second
referendum to see what everybody else
thinks of his new deal and if none of
the parties get a majority it will be a
hung parliament which for many people is
a complete nightmare because it probably
means more delay and
decision parties would have to come
together to find a way forward which
would likely mean a compromise on grexit
whoever gets in to number 10 will have
to work to a deadline and that's the
31st of January next year that's the
point at which the II use extension
given to the UK runs out and they warned
it could be our last there needs to be a
new deal by then a new extension if one
is allowed and if there isn't then the
UK may be leaving with no deal
[Music]